чого ангела меркель
чотири рази під час концерту немає шини на
адже президент США барак обама друкував
минулого візиту different обрив так
нашого ікалося як сценарію не можна його
зіб'ю я витягнувся праворуч німецького
народу ви вирішу ось ще при не самій
будні
нібито я б у ньому цем і мить бувало сулла
то я би Петро i move і не знаю на шкоду
цілей і хай допоможе
у сценарій 4 канцлерство мер коль
вписується це в пляму про право
дні літри з-за зустрічалася а зубам у
брюсселі три дні самого берліні
меркель пустий зал і хитайся
гравітаційним центром європейського кулі
так і тревал і що з ним тибул і задував
і не я км ерколь успішно навівав околицю
через закон імідж ну круїзу і адже ви
валу не менше але все і щури і солідним
про зростання ввп
цим were they та інших щур викроєних
з
i'm alone зрада ви робиш заради та
політику економії сильно жінка почали
консервативної партії ХДС біду пройдуть
людина в d партії до нових висот на
інших вибором табун ти став 2013
руку хдс набрала 41 соток sable
піки та політичної кар'єри вскоре
pudge а вся спад вольовим рішенням на
вид крила кордони не машини щур
біженців стало свого роду
ви прогуляли не у вогні ми і Петро їм
касири населення чи то главах владні
парку
схиблений фан я хочу ми що будемо
обурення ви бочата сизо ти ще в щура
у ситуації здалося дружніше вугілля
трудитися на мій околиця з сосни
mein land однак і знову на цю фразу ми
в часі йому систем багата німці в не
виділяють популярності та партії хдс
падаючи ти ж міркою по вдалося а Петро
mat і не висовуйся владні партії а
франк-вальтер штайнмаєр а сдп на посаду
федерального президента, що заселили
славтеся її політсили червоним ерколь
добрий стратег а джордж тут якщо вибори
2018 знову буде лика коаліція із суть
all демократам і померли всі шанси в 4
навчання ти німецької uri
хлопець дав рідко висадили на платформі